lundi 7 décembre toute la presse
européenne se réveille avec la gueule de
bois
marée noire le pen prend la france
triomphe de l'extrême droite fn premier
parti de france à l'instar de la presse
française les principaux journaux
européens constatent avec amertume
l'inexorable ascension de marine le pen
et s'interroge sur les blocages de ce
pays piliers de la construction
européenne terrorisme insécurité chômage
peur de l'étranger déception chronique
vis-à-vis des politiques de tous bords
les mots français sont nombreux et germe
dans les urnes
une réalité qui n'est pas seulement
hexagonale mais européenne autriche
pologne angleterre suède la vague
xénophobe touche la plupart des pays de
l'union
dans un message sur sa page facebook
matteo renzi premier ministre italien
met en garde l'europe l'europe doit
changer sans une vision stratégique
surtout en matière d'économie et de
croissance les forces populistes vont
gagner
si l'europe ne change pas son parcours
tout de suite les institutions
européennes risquent de devenir les
meilleurs alliés de marine le pen
une prédiction en forme d'ultimatum pour
l'europe et ses dirigeants